- Part of the idea of believing
that what happens to other
black people affects you
and recognizing that you're
not just an individual,
but that politically because
of the social marker of race,
and social stigma of race,
that your identity is salient
and that it makes sense
for people to join together
to try to collectively
improve their community
and their group status
within the community.
That also creates
opportunities for healing,
because you don't have
to suffer this alone.
Other people saw the exact
same thing that you do
that you did.
And if you talk about it right there
that's a way to help work through
some of that trauma together.
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to the first
episode of the Addy Hour.
I'm really excited to get
this program off the ground
and really thrilled to introduce
you to some great guests
as we talk through some really important
and some really deep content at times.
So just before we jump
into this first episode
I do wanna set the stage just a little bit
and to say that one of the things
that I'm really trying
to do on this podcast
is to pair unique individuals
from really different walks
of life who can come and share
on the same topic and share
from their unique perspectives
from their professional expertise
and from their what they're
going to experience.
So I think there's gonna
be a lot of great content
that we're gonna be able
to talk through together.
And I'm happy to be able
to bring that to you
through the series.
And with that, I'm
really excited to welcome
the first two guests on the program,
Dr. Jeff Gardere and Dr. Andra Gillespie.
So, welcome to both of you.
- Thank you.
- And these are names that
you definitely should know
if you don't, you'll
definitely know them well
after our conversation today,
but by way of brief introduction
did want to introduce both
of them to you before we
jump into the conversation.
So we'll start with Dr. Jeff Gardere.
He's also known as America's psychologist.
He's a clinical psychologist
who has a private practice in Manhattan,
and he's also an associate professor at
the Touro College of Osteopathic
Medicine in New York city.
Dr. Jeff has a very impressive background.
He's a very prolific author.
He's also contributed to documentaries
as a producer as well.
He's also been a period
on multiple national news outlets.
He's been on the Fox
Network on state show,
also on MSNBC and on CNN.
And in his own words
he has appeared on Ratchet
TV on occasion as well.
So I did want to mention that
but he's also a really devoted family man.
He's a father of six.
He has lots of great hobbies,
he really enjoys volunteering
enjoys giving back to the community
also enjoys daily exercise
and is very disciplined about that
and enjoys attending religious services.
So we're honored to have
Dr. Jeff on the program.
I should also mention he's a
interfaith ordained minister.
So several different
aspects that definitely tie
into what we want to bring out today.
So thanks for being here Dr. Jeff.
- It's a pleasure.
Wow. What an introduction.
I didn't even know half
those things about myself.
(Addy laughing)
Thank you.
- It's good to be reminded.
It's good to be reminded.
Also a pleasure to welcome
Dr. Andre Gillespie
to the program.
Andra's an associate professor
of political science at Emory University
and also the director of
James Weldon Johnson Institute
for the Study of Race and Difference.
And I definitely had to
read that because I don't
think I would've remembered
all of those words.
That's a very impressive
position that she has there.
She did her PhD training
at Yale university.
So there is a little
bit of an overlap there.
We did overlap at Yale
and our grad training.
It was great to be able to
reconnect with her in this way.
And embassy teaches a
host of different classes
on American politics, race and politics
and also on aspects of quality
the methodology in terms of her research,
she focuses on political leadership
of the post civil rights generation.
And she also does work
looking specifically
at African-American politicians
and political leadership
that transcends race
and how black voters respond
to those individuals.
So a lot of topics that she emphasizes
and studies on are really relevant
to the topics we'll be discussing today.
She's also an accomplished
author with numerous books.
She's an active public scholar,
also has written up
ads and done interviews
on numerous local and national
and international media outlets.
So, very grateful to
have Dr. Andra Gillespie
on the program today as well.
- Thank you.
So with that, before we get
into some of the nitty gritty
I just want to ask at the very baseline
how both of you all are doing in the midst
of everything that's
happening in our world today
everything that's happening
in your personal lives.
So Andra, why don't we start with you?
How are you,
how are you managing these
days with everything?
- I think I'm struggling managing
the same way that everybody else is.
My quarantine experience in part
because of the racial tension
and because I study
campaigns and elections means
that my work increased over the last year.
And so that's certainly
a challenge to try to
balance it out,
staying at home sometimes
makes it a little bit easier
to take on all of those responsibilities
but it's certainly given me a lot
of food for thought in terms
of what my post COVID life looks like
and what balance actually looks like
both during quarantine
and after quarantine.
And so I can't say that
I've perfected it though,
I've certainly learned a lot about myself
and learned a lot about what my limits are
and revisiting what my post COVID limits
and balance is going
to look like as I still
work to try to make sure
that I'm doing this right,
and making sure that I'm
being a balanced person.
I can't always say that I'm always
the most balanced in terms of my work.
(Jeff laughing)
- Yeah, well, definitely
appreciate that honesty.
And I agree with you in a lot of ways
that it really is something
that we're all learning over time.
And so I appreciate the way
that you mentioned that.
And also that it seems
that you're also giving
yourself grace to know
that it's not gonna be perfected
and there's things that you're learning
as you go and things
that you'll have to learn
on the other side as well.
And I think that's really healthy
for all of us to remember.
What about you, Jeff?
How are you, how are you managing
and handling things in this moment?
- Well, it's certainly
I can cry salty tears
as to what has happened politically.
And I know you'll be getting into that
to America and certainly how
the virus has been mismanaged
in the past year or so
seems like it's been forever certainly.
And we have a lot of high hopes
with the Biden administration to fix that.
And it looks like it is moving
forward on the right track.
But along with that,
and mourning the people who have died
and gotten sick and
certainly opened our eyes
to all of the political changes,
financial changes
sociological changes in the world
including the global warming and so on.
And, and just really watching that
in a way where I go to bed every night
with my mouth open.
I wake up every morning
I cannot believe what has
happened to our world.
At the same time,
it's also been a very strange
and beautiful existence being
in the house every single day.
I'm virtually in exile.
And I've chosen that a particular life
I've taken joy and pleasure in it.
Seeing my family every day,
seeing my children every day.
As a matter of fact,
I saw the kids a couple of
weeks ago in the kitchen,
and I had to ask my
wife who are those kids?
She was like, those are your kids.
I was like, wow.
Finally, I get to recognize
and spend time with them.
And I know Dr. Gillespie
perhaps goes through that too
but it certainly was
being home every day has
given me the time to pause and think
about what life is about and what it is
that I need to do once we
go back out into the world.
But I have to say this,
and I'll keep quiet after this.
If I never had to leave this house
or this property that I'm in
and you could see a little bit of it,
from my window.
If I never had to leave again,
I think I would just stay here
and work for the rest of my life.
And I'm a guy who's a Manhattan
Knight and all of that
but it certainly has changed things for me
in a very dramatic way as
it has for everyone else.
- Yeah.
I think that's very well said.
And I mean, so many important components
that you're bringing out as well.
All the changes that are
associated with everything
that we're going through
both the ones that are not good
and the ones where there
is some silver lining
there's some things that we're trying
to to grow in, in the meantime too.
So definitely appreciate you.
You bring those to light
and yes there's definitely
aspects of that,
we'll be looping back into
as we move forward in this conversation.
So both of you have hinted at
this already in terms of some
of these really important topics.
But I'm also curious you know,
what attracted you to this
podcast in particular?
Obviously there's numerous
podcasts out there.
You're both very prolific.
You're both in the media space.
There's lots of ways you
could be spending your time.
Why take the time to jump on here
and to jump into the conversation
in this space in particular.
Jeff if you wanna jump in, that'd great.
- Well, I certainly knowing
the work that you've done,
Nii's for me, it's been
just like absolutely amazing
that you bring a real clarity
into the things that we do
and why we do them.
And certainly I couldn't think
of a better podcast to be on.
And I get a lot of offers
like Dr. Gillespie,
to do these media hits and to do
these podcasts.
But I knew this is a place
where we can have not
just an intellectual, but
an emotional discussion
to try to figure out where
we are in this very upside
down world and how we make
it right side up perhaps
- Well said.
And I appreciate those kind words
and again the right side
up is definitely the goal.
What about you, Andra?
What pulled you in?
- Well, you asked.
(Addy laughing)
So of course I was going
to help you out and to honor,
I have known you and your
wife for almost 20 years
at this point.
You know, I had to admit
when I first heard,
what the topic was, my first
reaction was on the phone,
I had to talk about that
because my research isn't
about mental health.
But then,
through some additional conversation,
I realized that what you wanted me to talk
about was to talk about that context.
And so I can provide kind
of the political context
and then I can talk
about mental health from
a personal standpoint.
So I will say that kind of,
just as a preface, I'm not
a mental health professional
and same way the Dr. Jeff is.
So, you'll go to him for your
specific clinical advice.
And I, would be there
to affirm that the
things that you're seeing
may or may not be the way that they are.
- Yeah, very well said.
And we definitely
appreciate your willingness
to jump in in that way.
And I think that's part of the,
the beauty of it too.
Because as you hinted that we
don't always have these types
of interesting conversations.
Even though they definitely
influence one another.
So I'm hoping that's
something we can really unpack
in the conversation today
and in this series in general
as we do that with some of
the other topics as well.
But just to follow up on that, Andra,
if you could just give us
a little bit of a taste for
from your lens of what you see as our,
in a way our current
political health as a society.
what does that look like at the moment?
Where are we sitting?
- I wish I could be
optimistic and I am optimistic
because I do think that there is
the potential for reform
and the potential for
reconciliation and the often.
But if I had to look at the
current state of America
I have to acknowledge there are problems
and there are serious problems.
They didn't change before
or after January 6th
they didn't change before
or after January 20th.
And I think it's important
for us to realize
that America is just as sick
and just as divided
now with the new administration
as it was previously.
And it's gonna be really important
for us to spend the time.
I know people want to move past things
and sometimes they want to do
that for political reasons,
but it's important for us to diagnose
and address the problems that
brought us to January 6th
that brought us to the last four years,
because I think that,
that's more of a symptom
than a cause of anything in order
to address those issues and move forward.
So, all of the problems in
terms of partisan polarization
all the problems in
terms of racial division,
all of the problems in terms
of people jerking for position
and putting power and
sometimes party ahead
of what's good for the country,
all of the structural problems
that were laid bare by
what we've seen happen
in the last few years are still there.
And we could ignore it
and then kick the can down the road
and have another eruption in a few years
or we can try to address these
problems once and for all
and put us in a better position
so that we're more democratic.
So that, we're more just.
And what I see right now is a tension
between people who I think have the will
and the willingness to,
have those hard conversations
and people who don't want to
have those hard conversations.
And I think we need to recognize is
that those groups are actually more evenly
matched numerically than as some
of us perhaps would want them to be.
And so we're gonna have
to figure out a way to
bring people along to have that,
to have that moment where
they're actually willing to say that.
And so, I wish we could say
that we hit rock bottom on January 6th.
I'm not sure that that
is in fact, the case.
- Wow, there's a lot there.
And I appreciate you
just really digging in
and point out, you know,
the reality of these things.
I mean, these are more symptoms
than the core issue and the importance
for us to really be able to
dig in and address those.
And we're definitely
gonna come back to talk
about some of the things
that we need to do,
to be able to effectively work through it
and then move forward
and not just move on.
I thought why you brought
up some of those points.
I want to pivot to Jeff and just ask you,
in the midst of everything
that Andra just brought up
how does that impact us as a
society when we're thinking
about our emotional wellness
and our mental health?
What's the relationship between those?
- Well, I think certainly
with what Andra's pointed out
the political instability,
she didn't use these words,
but the continued racism
and white supremacy
and how it has been divisive
for our nation from the very beginning,
right up until now.
I think more than anything else
this has been an affirmation for us
that we as black and brown people
and those of us who are diverse
liberal whites, and so
on that we're not crazy.
We weren't making this up.
We weren't acting as victims.
This is something that is structural
and has been built into the foundation
of the United States and
many parts of the world.
And so that affirmation,
and I think for me
as a black person has lent
me a little bit more sanity
because it is the truth we are seeing.
What is part of what is going on
part of the process here and what it is
that we need to continue to address
and to try to fix.
But that being said
I've never seen so much
traumatization retraumatization
of black and brown people
by watching the images on television
and other media sources with
the capital insurrection
the way the individuals
were a very narcissistic,
acted out in a very unstable
ways were very determined,
in the way that they were attacked.
Now that we're finding out of course,
that there may have been
some coordination with
others within certain places.
I think all of those
things not only remind us
and are an affirmation, which in some ways
as I said is healthy
that now we know what we're seeing is real
but it also is a constant trauma
that we're seeing the
way that people act out
the way they're trying to stop us
from voting the continued oppression.
All of those things, I
think really contribute
to our post-traumatic stress disorder,
continue to contribute to our
post-traumatic slavery disorder
but continue to keep us
emotionally unstable.
And why now, we as mental
health professionals
have to address these issues in therapy
and really look at
positive mental attitude
spirituality, empowerment, strategies,
strategies working within
the political system
and every other system
to address these issues.
- Yeah, so important.
So important on so many fronts.
So you both brought out so
many important topics as well.
I think one thing that runs through
both of your comments
and something that a lot
of us talk about is that
these things aren't new.
So in some ways, sometimes
it's feels to some
like it's a new conversation,
but it really isn't.
I mean, these things have
been embedded in ongoing
and in a sense,
I do see some ways that
people are listening
with more of an ear for
empathy than they have
in the past,
at times where people
might have brushed it off
or just assume that those were
things that were happening
out there that weren't
really happening right here
where they were or weren't.
They didn't realize that these were things
that were happening to people they knew.
So even for me, as I've shared my story
that it's people feel shocked
that someone that they work with,
interact with,
is having these same
experiences in their minds.
Somehow they just put
that out there as other.
So, I think there is a
better understanding.
There's still a lot in the long
way to go in terms of that,
but really reconciling the fact
that these aren't fringe
episodes or fringe
things that are happening,
this is baked and it's happening
across the board in so
many different ways.
And then Jeff,
you talked about just all the
ramifications of that as well.
And so, as a mental health professional
and you start to talk
about this a little bit
in terms of some of the practice
but how do we deal with
the state that we're at
and really terms in terms of
trying to really address it?
And this ties into what Andra was talking
about in terms of the
political piece as well.
These aren't things that we can ignore
but we really have to dig in and say
we do need to address it.
So where do we start?
- Well, let me say this
to your prior point
what a difference a pandemic makes?
Because it is the pandemic
and everything that came along with it.
Of course, first we didn't understand
but now you can connect the dots.
We've never been through a
pandemic in our particular,
since the last a hundred years.
So, now we're seeing
how everything connects
but it is the pandemic itself
that really opened up the eyes
and the hearts of many
provided them the empathy to
understand what social
injustice looks like,
and what it feels like
and what people have been
going through forever,
because they were feeling the pain too.
This was a universal pain that actually
changed the trajectory of the world.
Absolutely extraordinary.
And so what we need to do
I believe in, and I'm
sure many people agree is
addressing the mental health
tsunami that came after
as part of this COVID-19 pandemic
that we are going through
can continue to go through.
And so that means now more than ever
not only addressing mental illness,
but the importance of mental health
as being part of our everyday lives.
It's not just about,
as you know I love to exercise every day
but we also now have
to exercise our minds.
We have to exercise our spirituality.
We have to be able to connect
with other people and talk about the pain
our informal support groups,
our formal support groups,
our therapy was seeing more people,
including people of
color coming into therapy
than ever before.
As a matter of fact, when we
look at the general population
a poll showed that one in six Americans
in 2020 actually accessed
mental health treatment.
And that is incredible.
In some ways it's very sad
that it had to happen that way.
In some ways it's very
encouraging in that,
finally we're addressing the importance
of being strong emotionally.
So those are the things we
have to keep pushing forward
and smashing that stigma of
talking about mental illness
in the black and brown
and other communities
and continuing to address
that every day actively.
- So well said, and in so many levels.
And yeah, as you mentioned
that it's encouraging,
disappointing and
encouraging at the same time,
but I think there's a lot that we can take
from that to say, okay,
well, look, we are starting to address it
and we're not just moving on.
And yes, we have made progress
in terms of decreasing
stigma, but you're right.
We still have to really smash
that ethos and get past that to really get
to a place where we can have healing.
And at the same token, Andra,
I was just curious to hear your thoughts
'cause you've talked about this
or you hinted at this already
and talked about it elsewhere.
What do we need to do to move forward
in terms of also equally importantly
addressing some of
these political tensions
that our city and that we've seen,
we've already seen when we ignore them
they just bubble up and more
than bubble up, they explode.
So what do we do to,
I almost wanna say prevent
that from continuing to happen as a cycle?
- That's really complicated and complex
because in the political arena,
people have to contend with the fact
that some people who actually
have helped to foment
the division are empowered.
And are likely to stay
in power structurally
because they're coming from districts
or they're coming
from States where people have
a diametrically opposed view
to the situation where you
have people who perhaps
believe that Donald Trump really
had the election stolen from him.
Or people who actually
see themselves pitted
against folks of the
opposing political party
and something that to
them would be existential
and equivalent to like
a partisan death match.
And so we have to figure
out as individuals
and then we actually have to
hold our leaders accountable
for figuring out ways to
lower the temperature.
And that's really difficult
in this moment when
not everybody is actually
willing to work together.
So actually it was just
teaching this in my class.
We've seen increasing evidence
of what we call negative partisanship.
So it was a concept that was coined
by one of my colleagues and
his graduate students at Emory.
And the idea of negative
partisanship is not
that I met political party per se
because of what I believe in,
but because I framed
it in a way that says,
I know I don't believe
what those other folks say.
And so while that can be clarifying
it also has the potential to other people.
And that has serious consequences when
we see people being othered,
taken to sort of,
it's in right.
That's when genocide happens, right?
Because if you think about historically
the ways that things have happened
like that's justified people feeling
that it's okay to inflict
violence against people
and to try to eliminate people.
And we've seen that in our rhetoric,
where you've seen social media posts,
where people think it's perfectly okay
to talk about executing
their political opponents.
I'm like, we shouldn't
be talking about that
in the United States that
runs counter to our ideals
that we need to acknowledge
historically how
people have been completely unabashed
and using violence when it
was convenient for their ends.
And whether that is sort of,
absolutely holding people up,
whether that's enslavement,
whether that is denying people,
their rights, like there's
just a lot of violence
in American history that
goes unacknowledged.
We have to say, no, stop.
That's unacceptable.
And I think even has to say
that this is unacceptable,
we rebuke and sometimes we've
removed people from office
even when we agree with them,
even when politically it's advantageous
to keep these folks in office
because they're gonna
vote the way that you want
on certain types of issues.
And that because of negative partisanship
because of polarization
is the unwillingness
that I've seen people do.
It's how you can have
somebody say, you know what,
I think Donald Trump caused a riot,
but I'm not gonna vote to like a victim
in an impeachment trial.
And if he runs for president
again, you know what?
I'm gonna support him, right?
Because we got the same
letter behind our name.
And I think people who are Democrats
also need to acknowledge
that there are people who would
use the same twisted logic
for a member of their own
party, if it met their end.
Right now I'm not trying
to create a false equivalency.
Because we saw a lot of that
in the last couple of weeks.
And I haven't seen
Democrats actually like,
try to start a riot recently right now.
But in theory, there could be
some crazy person who decides
that that is the way to go.
And Democrats would
then be on the hot seat
and have the responsibility
to stand up against that.
I think that we just need
some courageous people
more of them who are
actually willing to stand
up and speak truth to power,
wherever it is and actually
be willing to take the risk
of short-term political
loss of their careers.
I haven't seen that happen.
And so as voters
and we need to take that
voting responsibility seriously
and not just turn out in
record breaking numbers
because the country caught on fire.
And in some cases almost
literally when we think
about sort of,
the environmental disasters
that have happened in the West,
but that, look different
on the East coast where,
when we see flooding.
But like the country was literally on fire
because of COVID or because of wildfires
or because of demands for racial justice.
And all of a sudden everybody
realized what the stakes are.
Those stakes are important
when you're voting
for dogcatcher,
when you're voting for city council,
when you're voting for
your state legislatures.
And sometimes some of these people come
into sort of like their
public service careers
via some of these other routes.
And if you wanna stop that
and say that we don't stand
for that type of uncivil behavior.
We don't stand for people
who wanna be revisionist
in their history and deny
racism and deny marginalization.
You got to stop them wherever,
whatever level they're running for office,
even if they held office
for a long period of time.
And maybe even in the past
they've done nice things for you.
- Wow. There's a lot there.
So many things we could respond to.
I think you've pulled out again
so many important concepts.
And I think this piece about
whether it's reactionary versus
whether we're in this for the long haul
and really having some proactive measures
but I'm also curious
'cause you've painted a picture in terms
of what needs to happen
at a leadership level.
I'm curious,
what do you feel like
is the responsibility?
And you mentioned this as well,
but on the individual level
versus the large scale
leadership political level.
And if there's any
intersection between those two?
- I think that there's
a lot of intersection.
I think a lot of people think
that polarization is this thing
that people in Washington DC do.
Or that people may be doing
in their respective state capitals.
Now, those leaders come from the masses
and those leaders are getting
their cues from the masses.
And one of the things
that's actually been really
interesting is that, we always talk about
in person and in crisis of the past,
you heard about the difference
between trustee and
delegate representation
when we elect people.
Are they there to just
kind of put their finger up
in the wind and then just
vote the way that they think
that people in their
constituency want them to vote
or are they there to be
able to make tough decisions
maybe technical decisions that are based
on expertise and learning
and a lot of politicians
kind of use some
combination of both kind of
depending on which issue is at hand.
In the last month it's been
funny to see people go up
to their leaders and hold
them accountable if you will
because they were like,
we didn't send you there to think,
we sent you there to do our bidding.
And it was like, yeah, well,
sometimes true leadership means
that you stand up and say, you know what?
your personal opinion is based in a lie.
So, it's my responsibility
to show you that that's a lie
and then help bring you
to a different place.
But that also suggests that
there are people who can be easily led
into a type of mob mentality
where they're not thinking.
And so we have to guard ourselves
against sort of becoming part of the mob.
So part of that is making sure
that in terms of your
own media consumption
that you are guarding your heart.
So it's really nice to
go into your echo chamber
whatever echo chamber that is,
and only read and consume the stuff
that already confirms what you think.
Sometimes that stuff isn't true.
And there are some ways
that you can think about it.
So like the tools that I give
to my students are,
watching cable news,
prime time gets really
opinionated certain time of day,
eight to 11,
nine to 11 in particular, right?
Those folks may be journalists.
They may not be journalist.
So you should know the
background of your TV posts
and know sort of like
when they're actually
like spouting off of their opinion
versus when they're delivering hard news.
You should know when
they have round tables
kind of like, who are the journalists,
who are the political hats,
who were there,
who's there to be objective to
provide outside information.
Also you should vet sources.
So if one news outlet
is reporting something
and other credible
establishment news outlets
are not reporting it,
you might be suspect they
could be on the Vanguard
and other folks could catch up eventually.
But that is a clue that one
news source is picking it up
and other people aren't that
there, this may not be true.
So I would, not necessarily
forward that on Facebook,
if you can't verify the
source of what's going on.
And then, there are other
places that are trusted
where these people have no
idea what they're doing.
These people don't have any training.
They don't have accountability.
They don't have any editors.
You shouldn't be
listening to that as well.
And I wouldn't trust any
news source that doesn't have
an ombuds person,
and that doesn't have a
history of retractions, right?
Because all journalists make mistakes.
And the difference between
journalism and propaganda
is that journalists will correct mistakes.
Propagandists don't.
And so you have to understand what it is
that you're listening to.
And it's okay sometimes to cut it off
even though news is on 24 hours a day
you don't have to watch it 24 hours a day.
You should probably go
spend time with your family.
And the real news will still
be there when you get there.
- Yeah, that's really good.
You're, touching on some
of the mental health too.
He already put in some of those practices
you made your disclaimer
about not being a mental health expert.
But I think you've got some good tools
that you're sharing with
our listeners already,
but I think,
everything you've mentioned is so spot on.
Jeff, I was curious with everything
that Andra has mentioned.
How you advise people as
she's been talking about
in their media consumption
both in terms of how much to take in,
but then also in terms of
what she's talking about,
about discernment?
And how how do we react
to some of those things?
Because some of the things
that are happening are real
and we've touched on
that it affects people
but how do you guide people in terms of
those responses to
everything that's happening
in politics and in the media?
- Well, Andra was spot on with her advice.
And one of the things that we say
as mental health experts is
know when you've reached
your saturation level.
When it comes to consuming the news
be able to get what it is that you want
because breaking news
is the same news that's
being played over and over
and over and over again.
And so breaking news,
ain't what it used to be.
So you can get that information quickly
and then once you get it,
then go on to something
else that relaxes you
as you are absolutely
processing that information.
And as well as she has said,
again, the importance of getting it
from different news sources,
because certainly you
don't want your information
to be homogeneous
because then you're not
getting different opinions.
It's not allowing you to think.
It's not allowing you to process it
by hearing the different voices
and giving you a much more information.
But one of the most
important things that I think
that you should really consider
is that we've lost many friendships.
We've lost many family connections
because of the partisan politics.
What it is that we're hearing in the news?
What it is that we have come to believe?
And so it's important
that you stay connected
to your friends, to your family,
to people that you may work with,
who not only have the same opinions
but especially who have
differing opinions,
because they're you find common ground
you try to find common ground,
you learn something new.
It's not only the intellectual processes
that increase but also your social IQ,
but more than anything else you want
to maintain those
connections with other people
because it goes beyond the news.
It goes to your humanity
and learning how to live in a world,
how to live in a country,
where people have differing opinions
but you can respect their opinions,
especially if they're not based on hate
and racism and prejudice
but are based more than anything
on having different perceptions.
That's what's always made America
when it has been great, great.
But that's what makes us as human beings
the social kinds of people that we are
it's important to
maintain those connections
especially in times like these.
- Yeah. I think that's so important.
You've both made so many great points.
I think there's so much rich content
that people can really dig into here
and really think about aspects where,
we've all fallen short.
We're human, especially
in this time with COVID.
I think one of the main
things that we've had to
we emphasize for ourself.
I know I've had to reemphasize
for my students as well
is to give ourselves
at times to know that
things are more difficult
than they usually are.
And there are gonna be a lot more missteps
than we're typically accustomed
to taking in the first place.
But to again have that willingness
to be able to forgive ourselves
and forgive those around us.
I guess I think that gets to
your point, Jeff, as well.
And to add just a point about
really being able to get
and have community beyond the differences.
Andra, I think you hit
that point very early on
as you were talking about just how
the differences are so deep seated.
And you've talked about some
of the frameworks from
how people are focusing
on the othering more and more
than they have in the past.
Not that it wasn't there
in the past in other ways
but how dangerous that
can be in a lot of ways.
So definitely appreciate
both the points that you
are pulling out in this conversation.
As we wrap up, I did
want to just talk briefly
about some of the additional
steps that we think
about in communities of color
as well and how we move on.
So, or how we try to move on
after having moved through.
So there was an article
in the New York times,
a couple of weeks ago,
specifically from black staffers who were
at the Capitol working on January six.
And they talked a lot
about their specific
traumatization that happened
in that moment.
I'm they assumed that of all
places as black individuals
in this country,
that they would be safe
in that environment
and all the fears that they had
fear for losing their
lives in that situation.
And then all of the
stress that they've known,
they felt after the fact
and even just saying,
sometimes if we haven't gone through it
the post-traumatic stress can feel
like it's an intellectual
thing that we're talking about.
Once you go through a situation like that
then you realize, okay, this is real.
And so I'm curious from both of you
how is as for black individuals,
all the ramifications of that moment
and how we process that moving forward
both from a political framework
and also from our mental health framework.
- So this might sound a little weird,
but in some ways I think
that there were affirming moments
as tragic as this was,
I think it is important to
acknowledge that for many folks,
this wasn't a surprise.
Like we knew that white
supremacy has sort of,
violent goals and that they
could manifest themselves.
And I don't think anybody
woke up per se on January 6th
other than the people who were planning
that riot and expected that to happen.
But on the other hand,
people who are on with the knowledge
that white supremacy is violent
weren't shocked by what they saw.
Even though as citizens in the moment,
you can be shocked and horrified
but what it is that you're seeing.
And so I used the term affirming to say
that it affirms what people knew deep down
in their core about racism.
So that you're not shocked
or surprised by what you saw.
And it also counters
those who wanted to say
that America isn't racist
or that America was past race,
we took care of all of that in the 1960s.
Shortly after Barack Obama
there is no such thing as
racism in America anymore.
Donald Trump was doing mapping off.
We knew that, that was made bare.
And there's a strange comfort in knowing
that you weren't crazy that
your experience is real
and that it is tied to the
experience of other people.
And the other thing that I think is really
interesting is sort of
this idea of community.
And I think that there are
mental health applications
for this in political science.
We always talk about group consciousness
within the African-American community.
We talk about a political
psychological concept called linked fate
which makes it highly predictive
of African-American political behavior.
And in terms of policy preferences
in terms of voting behavior
and other kinds of things.
It's that thing that makes
black people look alike
even though there's a lot
of heterogeneity in black communities.
But part of the idea of
believing that what happens
to other black people affects you
and recognizing that you're
not just an individual,
but that politically because
of the social marker of race
and the social stigma of race,
that your identity is salient
and that it makes sense
for people to join together
to try to collectively
improve their community
and their status within the community.
That also creates
opportunities for healing,
because you don't have
to suffer this alone.
Other people saw the exact
same thing that you do,
that you did.
And if you talk about it,
that's a way to help work through some of
that trauma together because
part of the trauma is isolation.
Is feeling that you're the only one
and you weren't.
There were lots of people who saw that
and they weren't always all black,
who saw that.
But in particular with respect
to the African-American community,
yeah, I would say
probably the vast majority
of the 44 million
of us in the United
States kind of saw that
and understood what was going on.
And there's a way for us
to be able to work together
and combat that.
And I think you, there's
some lessons like,
post-traumatic trauma and
stress have been around.
They may not have been named
as such in previous generations
but we have a name for it now,
and we can talk through it.
And sometimes I think that
there are important lessons here
for how we talk about bad things,
and I will leave it to Jeff to talk
about when it's appropriate to
bring this up with children.
But I think perhaps some of the shock
particularly for people who are younger is
that they thought America
was past all of this
in the last six years,
seven to eight years have shown us that,
we're really not past all of this.
But I actually
as troubling and as dissatisfied
and as frustrated as I can be,
that I can look back at what happened
in the fifties and what was happening
in the 19 teens and twenties
and what was happening
in the 1880s and 1890s sort
of shows this common thread.
There's the frustration
of why are we still kind
of treading the same
ground that we had before
but there's also a comfort
in knowing other people
saw this, name this
tried to combat it,
and that we have an opportunity
to kind of push the ball forward
farther than they were able to
because of the tools and the freedoms
that we have at our disposal.
And I think
it's better to have intergenerational
discussions about this
so that people don't understand that,
this is the first time
we're experiencing this.
And sometimes our elders
have tools that they
haven't always imparted to us
because they were trying
not to traumatize us.
And that wasn't a healthy way
for them to deal with their trauma.
And it's not a healthy way to help us deal
with our trauma today.
So I see opportunities.
And so that's why I'm
calling it affirming.
Not that I think that what happened
on January six is a good thing
because of course that was horrible.
- Well, that's so good.
- I agree.
I agree.
And specifically going to this question
about black journalists and
what they've been through
we know that they've been
traumatized and retraumatized.
They are having some real issues dealing
with the dichotomy
of reporting the news
and telling the truth
but telling it in a way
that doesn't get them
in trouble with the parent organization
where there may be people who
are extremely conservative
who may own those news outlets
or getting people really angry
the general public, their readers,
the people who watch them
by talking about what's
really in their hearts.
So they have to keep it
extremely professional
and just report it in a way
that reporting is usually done
not putting your emotions in it,
especially if you just
giving straight news.
So they're facing the wrath
of some people in that way who are saying
we don't want to know about
your black experience.
They're facing the wrath
of people who are saying
why aren't you telling us more
about your black experience?
And then we know that traditionally
that black journalists,
black broadcasters,
and so on,
there's been systematic
institutional sorts of racism
prejudice in the places that they work
where they have been treated traditionally
as second and third class citizens
not being given their due feeling
like they are an outside group.
I know this because I've done a lot
of the work with these journalists.
And so traditionally there's been a PTSD
as Andra has talked about.
They've experienced it
in all of these avenues
but especially with what's
going on in the world right now
around COVID and around,
political oppression
and social injustice.
But at the same time, we also know
and this is life in COVID worlds.
We also know that it's important
for them to be able to hook
up with affinity groups
so that they can talk
about some of their issues
and as well be able to
connect with one another
with regard to informal support
groups within their networks
and also getting that therapy too.
- Yeah. So I'll start by both of you,
and yes that's definitely a COVID life
as you've demonstrated for us very well.
- Did you see the mom at
the, on the floor saying
come back here.
- In my mind, I envisioned that.
(Addy laughing)
so many important points.
I think you've both
just the affirmation and
the tension that's there.
And Jeff has even mentioned
with the journalist
and I think for all of us
in a lot of different ways
and I think that's part of the challenge
for us really moving
forward is to be able to
to lean into that,
to both of those aspects
and not ignore either one of those.
Andra, I love the point that
you mentioned about the
elders bringing in aspects
that they can help us
with through as well.
Whereas some of those things
might not have been spoken
about before for fear of retraumatization,
but that as we're all
going through it already,
the time is definitely appropriate.
There's so much more that
we could have jumped into.
I definitely appreciate both
of you being here and for the listener
this is obviously an ongoing
conversation we'll be having
from different angles on
the Addy Hour moving forward
but I'm deeply appreciative
to both Dr. Jeff Gardere
and Dr. Andra Gillespie for
joining on this first episode
for really launching in and
giving us a lot to think
about and these are conversations
that as you'll see,
we'll have some takeaways
but there's things that
we'll also be able to
continue to think about
throughout the week.
So again, just deeply appreciative to both
of you for being willing to jump in
on this first episode for
really setting the tone
for how things will go moving forward.
- Thank you.
It was an honor and a pleasure
to be on the Addy Hour
and to spend the time also with you Andra
you are spot on and everything you say
and I can to you forever,
but I'll be...
- I appreciate that.
I have liked you for years
so, this has been fun.
- Thank you.
But I'll be listening
to you on the Addy hour.
(Andra and Addy laughing)
- Thanks again, to both of you
and for our listeners
stay tuned for some
great episodes coming up.
(upbeat music)